a woman who accuses Bill Cosby of sexual
assault is scheduled to take the stand
today in his retrial andrea constand
says Cosby drugged and molested her at
his home in 2004 Cosby says their
encounter was consensual the 80 year old
comedian is charged with three counts of
aggravated indecent assault Michelle
Miller is following the trial Michelle
good morning good morning
well prosecutors called five of Cosby's
accusers to the stand this week former
supermodel Janice Dickinson testified
yesterday claiming Cosby drugged and
sexually assaulted her but a memoir she
wrote more than 15 years ago suggests
discrepancies in her story on the fourth
day of Bill Cosby's sexual assault
retrial the comedian's publicist fired
off against one of the lawyers
representing dozens of his accusers it's
awful what she's doing a characterizing
herself as a civil rights attorney
putting these women on the witness date
I don't put anybody on the witness stand
it's the prosecutor who decides on the
witness stand
attorney Gloria Allred's daughter Lisa
bloom represents Janice Dickinson who
took the stand yesterday to testify that
Cosby drugged and sexually assaulted her
at a Lake Tahoe hotel in 1982 she
testified I didn't consent to this here
was America's dad on top of me a married
man father of five kids on top of me I
was thinking how wrong it was how very
wrong it was defense attorney Tom
Mesereau challenged dickinson in
cross-examination pointing out that she
made no mention of sexual assault in her
2002 autobiography it's all a
fabrication in there she answered it was
written by ghostwriters I wanted a
paycheck we feel and believe that these
truths and facts that we heard today
sure result in mr. Cosby found not
guilty of all charges
now another accuser Lisa Lott Lubin was
the fifth person to testify yesterday
she claims that Cosby drugged and
sexually assaulted her in 1989 Cosby
denies that constant appearance today
will be the second time she faces a jury
after the previous trial ended without a
verdict
Michelle following the bouncing ball for
us thanks Michelle